mais d'abord elle servait jusque-là
assurer la sécurité des tourangeaux
elles permettront aussi bientôt de les
verbaliser et des caméras de l'hyper
centre de tours outils de sanction des
stationnements gênants ou n'en compte
7000 chaque année à partir de lundi
prochain la police municipale pourra
donc dresser des pv à distance
explications avec hélène chapelet
22 panneaux de ce type viennent d'être
déployés sur la ville de tours le
message est clair désormais en cas de
stationnement gênant plus besoin
d'agents sur place pour constater le
délit
tout se fera à distance grâce aux 130
caméras de vidéosurveillance installées
sur la voie publique
fini donc la tolérance pour les
stationnements sur le trottoir sur un
passage piéton devant un accès pompiers
le tout autre endroit inapproprié
on va constater que le nombre de
stationnements gênants de signalements
pour stationnement gênant était en
constante augmentation et l'année
dernière en 2020 malgré le continent
malgré la circulation qui a beaucoup
diminué pendant plusieurs mois on est
arrivé à 7000 signalement pour
stationnement gênant la politique suivie
jusqu'ici était plutôt laxiste oui on
avait pour habitude à tour deux mois
verbaliser le stationnement gênante et
dans d'autres villes de france et c'est
ici au centre de supervision urbain que
les amendes à 135 euros pourront être
dressée à partir du 18 janvier prochain
vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre
plusieurs opérateurs surveillent la
ville désormais quand ils vont repérer
un véhicule en infraction ils pourront
agir grâce aux caméras
l'agent va dans un premier temps prendre
un cliché avec l'outil de manière à
faire un plan d'ensemble et de
comprendre la situation globale ensuite
il fera un plan plus rapprochée de
manière à ce qu'on ait les moyens
d'identification du véhicule donc la
marque le modèle la plaque
d'immatriculation
et puis on va laisser un laps de temps
de cinq minutes de manière à relever à
travers un deuxième cliché un dernier
cliché l'infraction dans sa globalité le
procès verbal électronique sera ensuite
finalisés grâce à ce téléphone et
arrivera chez les particuliers comme une
amende classique
quant aux clichés pris ils serviront de
preuve en cas de contestation de la part
du propriétaire du véhicule